[Music]
now this is a guess because I wasn't
there and we don't have any clear
records of this period of history but at
some point in the early history of life
on earth it's very likely nothing could
move cells existed where they were they
got sloshed around through physical
processes and survived when they ended
up by chance in some place that had the
necessary chemicals for them to continue
their lives and reproduce if that didn't
happen they just died but since food is
never evenly distributed on our world
and also sometimes you are food being
able to move is fantastic and so it has
been selected for pretty intensely so
that now in the micro cosmos almost
everything moves but before we get to
how they do it we have to confront a
reality you need to forget everything
you know about swimming things do not
work the same when you are tiny you and
I are constantly moving through a fluid
it's just hard to feel it air it's
barely there until you stick your hand
out of a car window on the highway then
you feel that fluid but for a tiny grain
of pollen air is a thick fluid that can
keep it airborne for days now sink that
tiny grain of pollen into far more
viscous water and it's basically in a
sticky glue imagine being completely
submerged in honey and you have a vague
idea of what it's like swimming in the
micro cosmos which is why in that
microscopic world when something stops
moving it just stopped
you and I if we push through the water
we'll coast for a bit as our momentum
carries us forward but for a single cell
the viscosity of the water overcomes
that inertia instantly this can lead to
organisms looking as if they're moving
somewhat unnaturally to our eyes which
is we think why we've had several people
ask us if our footage is sped up but no
unless it says so on screen all of our
clips are in real time these little
folks can just move and they need to
move to search for food to avoid
predators to get into or out of sunlight
to move toward chemicals they need or
away from chemicals that poison them and
the wild thing is with all the diversity
of microscopic life single-celled
eukaryotes basically all move around in
three or maybe four different ways how
organisms move is so important and so
obvious when they're observed that
protozoans
which is the general name for
single-celled eukaryotes are actually
loosely classified by their style of
movement
we've got ciliates which move using the
cilia flagella --tz-- which move using
flagella and amoeboid which move using
pseudopodia oh and then there's
sporozoites oh you a picture of for
reasons that will become clearer
sporozoites never move and when they do
it's in a very weird limited way and the
reason we can't show you a picture of
one is that they are every one of them
parasites
many of them live inside of and cause
disease in animals so we choose to you
know not keep them around but overall
among eukaryotes we've got cilia
flagella and pseudopodia we're gonna
start with the shapeshifters of the
micro cosmos amoeba
these cells can change their shape as
they wish allowing them to extend parts
of themselves and two features called
pseudopodia these extend in the
direction they want to move and then
solidify as the cell moves into the
newly occupied space pseudopodia is
Latin for basically false feet and these
extensions which are half reaching arm
half cell body or how these crawlers
move and hunt the secret here is that
the cytoplasm of an amoeba can be easily
changed from a fluid state into a solid
state and back again when an amoeba
moves liquids cytoplasm flows through
the center up to the tip of the
pseudopod and the new gushes to the
sides where it becomes more of a solid
gel allowing the cell to lock into its
new location predatory amoeba create
these extensions in all directions to
trap prey between them once the prey
organism is surrounded by the
pseudopodia the amoeba simply swallows
it the two other main mechanisms of
eukaryotic movement cilia and flagella
are more common and they're actually
really similar both functionally and
structurally at the molecular level
though they look like rods sticking
through the surface they're actually
extensions of the cell membrane wrapped
around rigid tubes called microtubules
that are anchored in place however
hydrodynamically they're very different
there are usually an easily countable
number of flagella per cell whereas
ciliated organisms have huge numbers of
cilia the word cilia actually comes from
the Latin word for eyelash which makes
sense is you can sometimes see them
ringing a cell as our eyelashes ring our
eyes but in those cases the cilia
actually often cover the entire cell
they're just harder to spot against the
background of all the stuff on the
inside
cilia move organisms by beating in waves
over their surface a cilium which is the
singular of cilia because Latin has only
two possible positions during the
effective stroke the psyllium sticks out
perpendicular to the cell and during
recovery it folds back towards the cells
surface in most ciliates the cilia are
arranged in rows and the cilia of a road
don't move all together at once when
some of the cilia are in the effective
stroke others are in the recovery stroke
and in some ciliates you can see the
wave pattern this creates and these
waves are basically grabbing on to the
sticky viscous water yanking the cell
through one added complication here some
ciliates
have dense bundles of cilia called seri
seri are used to walk on a solid
substrate rather than pulling the
organism through the water though it's
the same structure it is a bit of a
different system of movement
now on to eukaryotic flagella the motion
of most flagella is characterized by
this long wave like beating pattern
beginning from the base of the flagella
and moving out to the tip this is fake
Aslam dakoda we recorded this footage in
phase-contrast which makes the
transparent parts of the cell more
visible so you can see the beating
flagellum better can you see it at the
tip of the cell fakest long Dakota is a
photosynthetic flagella it uses sunlight
to produce sugar you can see the
chloroplasts in the cell like green peas
and the round transparent part in the
middle of the cell is a starch like
carbohydrate storage unit called para
Milam
now of course as always the deeper you
look the more confusing and amazing
things get diatoms are sometimes
completely non-modal
but some species can also move by
excreting mucus through their cell
slowly propelling them over a substrate
and finally we said nothing in this
entire video about the marvelous
movements of prokaryotes like bacteria
and they have systems every bit if not
more ingenious than their more complex
eukaryotic friends but they are also
tiny so tiny that these structures can't
be observed by microscopes like the ones
we use so we just have to be content
knowing that they use structures that
function similarly to their structures
eukaryotes use but that are made of
completely different stuff and all of
these chemical structures eukaryotic and
prokaryotic so complex and marvelous
were selected for through billions of
years of evolution and almost shockingly
just a few extremely effective systems
of locomotion were uncovered the result
we can watch them these little balls of
chemicals working to get what they need
they are each a little soup that once
look at them one ting
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us if you want to see
more from our master of microscopes
Jains check out Jam and germs on
Instagram and if you want more from us
we've got a few videos over at
youtube.com slash micro cosmos and we
put out a new one every week we've been
doing a pretty good job of keeping on
top of it so thanks for liking what we
do